19:29 and the cool acts are in trouble
who would the cool acts you ask well the
cool acts were farmers specifically
wealthy farmers who lived in the USSR
whose leader Joseph Stalin didn't
appreciate their acquired wealth for
there are objections to his policies the
policy that the cool acts particularly
disliked was collectivization this was
the process of forcibly taking land from
individual peasant farmers and combining
them with others under joint control but
under the close watch of the government
these farms call causes were ideally
supposed to be more efficient and could
produce much more food for the growing
cities of the Soviet Union shockingly
peasants who had been given their land
by Lenin were unhappy at having it taken
away from them and so naturally they
resisted these people weren't given much
of a choice there were many were either
deported beaten until the acquiesced or
were simply shot over the next three
years over 300,000 kulaks were deported
either to faraway settlements or to work
camps so collectivization had one major
flaw it didn't work
crop yields on collective farms were
lower than individually held ones and in
1931 and 1932 grain yields dropped
precipitously there were many reasons
for this such as bad weather pests and
you know the fact that people with
farming knowledge had just been sent to
work camps the decline in crop UITs was
particularly severe in Ukraine which had
seen much higher rates of
collectivization shockingly without
crops there was less food and less food
meant starvation and famine Stalin was
further embarrassed when Ukrainian
peasants fled the USSR for Poland and
quickly spread word of the famine to the
wider world sight note it's worth noting
that the family didn't simply affect
Ukraine it was widespread throughout the
USSR but mostly affected the south so
how did the Soviet government respond to
the famine the government created a
bread ration for major cities like the
Ukrainian capital of Kharkov but those
in the countryside ie those who grew the
food were left with little interestingly
those who had previously been deported
to forced labor camps were often given
larger daily rations than those who
worked on the farms or lived in the
cities Lazar Kaganovich Stalin's second
in command ordered stanislav castillo
the leader of the ukrainian communist
party to crack down on the peasantry the
government was concerned that starving
Ukrainians fleeing Ukraine with
demoralizing the rest of the USSR and
would make collectivization and the
Stalin look bad as such the government
chose to pull back on collectivization
in ukrainian just kidding they bound
people from moving throughout the USSR
and denied that any famine was happening
furthermore any discussion surrounding
starvation was seen through the lens of
being a hunger strike orchestrated by
Polish spies and Ukrainian nationalists
also during the famine the Soviet Union
was still exporting grain in simply
halting this or opening up the nation's
extensive grain reserves would have
alleviated a great deal of the suffering
Stalin didn't want to though since the
money raised from selling grain was used
to build heavy industry across the
nation this period known as the
Holodomor
or the terra famine continued until 1933
when crop yields began to increase and
were able to feed the now much lower
population estimates vary with the death
toll of the famine in Ukraine is
considered by historians to be at about
roughly 3 million in fact when the USSR
conducted a census in 1937 the figures
for the population were lower than
anticipated and so Stalin had those who
compiled it shocked the big debate
surrounding this event is whether or not
it should be labeled as the genocide and
to what extent who was responsible not
however is a debate for another video I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching and a special thanks to
all of these patrons you see on screen
for their generosity in supporting the
show and a particularly special thanks
to James Bissonnette party-boy Co
Michael Reynolds Gustav Swann Winston
Cawood Skye Chappell Adam Harvey Gable
Rihanna's ARCA flash
you